l'épidémie de grippe au plus haut en
France en ce début d'année regardez sur
cette carte toutes les régions sont
concernées en ce qui concerne le covid
la situation s'améliore le pic qui
apparaît en jaune foncé semble derrière
nous obtenir un rendez-vous chez un
médecin généraliste sera encore
compliqué cette semaine les médecins
libéraux poursuivent leur grève et
manifesteront jeudi partout en France en
temps normal il serait dans son
laboratoire à préparer des pâtisseries
mais son initiative fait de lui l'homme
du jour qui attire tous les médias ce
boulanger de Rillieux dans l'Oise refuse
de payer sa dernière facture
d'électricité la hausse restera
plafonnée dans notre pays je le dis en
particulier à nos artisans nos
boulangers mais aussi à nos entreprises
les plus industrielles dès demain vous
aurez DZ adaptées en plus du bouclier
tarifaire déjà mis en place il y a
quatre jours il reçoit cette facture
astronomique
12 8882 euros en décembre contre 1000
euros en septembre dernier
intenable pour sa pâtisserie dont le
chiffre d'affaires atteint 20.000 euros
par mois je remarque que Monsieur Macron
dans ses vœux a dit bon pour moi il a
repris la proposition de Marine Le Pen
en disant il faut que le prix
d'électricité soit le prix de production
française donc qu'on arrête de se faire
un an et demi même en année au deuxième
hiver ou Monsieur le Maire Monsieur
Macron nous promet une réforme faut pas
une réforme je sais qu'on février je ne
pourrais plus payer les factures
on va fermer quoi les crèches on va puis
chauffer les cantines qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire dans les écoles on met pas de
chauffage et je n'ai aucune réponse
parce que j'ai interrogé et le problème
c'est la non-réponse c'est-à-dire que
moi j'ai interrogé à la fois les
services de l'État et je n'ai aucune
réponse politique ne fait plus rien il
ne fait plus que la com et il agit à
court terme est-ce qu'il peut faire
quelque chose
s'il avait du courage mais il n'en a pas
les adieux auront appelé qui se
poursuivent là où tout a commencé
c'est-à-dire dans le stade de la ville
de Santos c'est là que le triple champ
du monde à forger une grande partie de
sa légende et vous le voyez sur ces
images en direct les Brésiliens viennent
lui rendre hommage ils ont 24 heures
pour le faire et puis au Vatican c'est
le corps de Benoît XV qui est exposé
depuis aujourd'hui et jusqu'à mercredi
avant des funirail jeudi elles seront
présidées par le pape François une
situation inédite dans l'histoire Benoît
XVI est décédé samedi à l'âge de 95 ans
mais à l'occasion d'une question sur la
guerre en Ukraine l'acteur en a profité
pour interpeller les Français sur leur
perception des guerres dans le monde
comme j'ai de la famille ailleurs en
Afrique je sais qu'il a toujours eu des
enfants en guerre des familles brisées
ça veut dire que quand c'est en Afrique
vous êtes moins atteint l'acteur dénonce
l'intérêt que porte les français pour la
guerre en Ukraine alors qu'il se
préoccupe moins des autres conflits dans
le monde c'est là où je trouve le
commentaire de Marcy sans doute injuste
il y a 58 soldats français qui sont
morts dans l'opération barkhane parce
que la France plus que tout autre pays
se préoccupe de la sécurité en Afrique
du terrorisme islamiste en Afrique et à
payer le prix du sang pour ça
compréhension et soutien de la député
insoumise clémentinotin ça n'est juste
colère merci
Omar Sy monsieur combien a-t-il
accueilli de réfugiés africains dans sa
villa c'est facile de donner des leçons
aux Français qui ont accueilli qui
accueille des réfugiés Ukrainiens mais
même des réfugiés africains pour les
politiques le Nouvel An c'est une
nouvelle occasion de se démarquer avec
des vœux originaux dans une vidéo
publiée sur les réseaux sociaux le
patron du PS Olivier Faure se lance dans
une fausse partie de Monopoly rebaptisée
Macron poli je vois cette image je vous
assure je suis dans les caricatures de
la libre parole de Drumont quand je vois
ça bon avec optimiser pollué frauder
profiter voilà comment est présenté
Emmanuel Macron pendant 3 minutes il
affronte le supposé président de la
République et pris sa politique la
baisse de l'indemnisation chômage
l'inaction la réforme des retraites à
venir et le recours aux 49-3 franchement
une vraie chance de métier bon mais
vraiment et écoutez écoutez son clips